it's almost December and that means one
more batch of free games for PlayStation
Plus subscribers this year think of it
like a holiday present for Sony fans if
you want to know what you'll be
unwrapping this month I've got you
covered
first up ps4 is getting Darksiders to
definitive edition on top of being kind
of annoying to say this rerelease of the
cult classic includes a prettier and
more balanced version of the base game
plus all the previously released DLC I
guess the apocalypse is a good way to
close out the Year ps4 is also getting
Kung Fu Panda showdown of legendary
legends it's also kind of a dumb title
to say out loud but this family-friendly
fighting game pits a bunch of characters
from the movie against each other it's
like Smash Brothers but with a Jack
Black sound alike but wait there's more
in celebration of PlayStation VR s
one-year anniversary
you can still grab until dawn on rush of
blood this spin-off isn't about making
dialogue choices for a bunch of teens
it's a shooting gallery where you're
strapped into a crazy bloody
rollercoaster like the rest of these
games it'll only be available until
January 2nd on the ps3 side the winter
months are getting appropriately cold
with Siberia collection which includes
the first two games in the series these
graphic adventures sent protagonist Kate
Walker across Europe in search of an
heir to a toy factory ps3 players can
also try out X plays lost memories just
like Siberia this game is all about
searching for someone but in this case
your sister is lost in an alternate
world called the phantom field get ready
to get weird as for the Vita Sony's
handheld is getting wanted Corp this
top-down shooter puts you into the shoes
of two different bounty hunters each
with their own powers and you'll have to
use both if you want to blast your way
to a high score in every level and
finally Vita owners can also explore an
alien planet with forma 8 this
Metroidvania certainly looks pretty but
you'll still have to master new powers
and take down big bosses to get through
it all thanks to cross by you can have
the same experience on ps4 as well and
those are your free PS Plus games for
December they'll be available
starting Tuesday December 5th until
January 2nd you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles over at GameSpot and if you want
to keep up with all of our top stories
you can grab the official game spot now
app on iOS and Android
[Music]
you